[musique]
matériaux parce que ce qui est sous l'eau
ce n'est pas visible, c'est comme une plage
propre ici tout est bien rangé A
ce qui se passe au fond les gens ne le savent pas et
[musique]
moins de déchets Eh bien, en général, notre désir
pour qu'il soit possible d'y plonger du tout
s'il s'agit d'une tendance, nous aurons
réjouis-toi quand il y est retourné beaucoup
nettoyer et c'est quand ce sera
devenir plus petit
[musique]
Et quand il y a plus de touristes
ils le font généralement bien assis il se repose
et ils y jettent des graines, ils y jettent des mégots
plage là-bas
cacher leurs abonnements
Bien sûr, nous leur demandons là-bas pour qu'ils ne
l'ont fait mais ils le font habituellement
cela et derrière cela nous devons tous
le nettoyage c'est bien
une bonne eau propre pour que tout reste propre
souhaite aussi à tous les vacanciers
apporté les produits laissés